قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
كنعاني ان بلاده ترفض الاتهامات الامريكيه
الموجهه لها بشان استهداف السفن في المياه
الدوليه مؤكدا ان الاتهامات لا قيمه لها
ويتم طرحها لاهداف سياسيه حسب
تعبيره بزتر متهمان تح
د واشنطن تعتبر المتهم الاول في التطورات
التي نشهدها خلال الشهرين الماضيين وهي
تتحمل المسؤوليه الكامله عن الحرب
واستمرارها لاكثر من شهرين الولايات
المتحده ليست في موقف يسمح لها بتوجيه
الاتهامات لنا او لاي طرف في المنطقه هذه
الاتهامات مرفوضه تماما ولا اساس لها ولا
قيمه لها ويتم طرحها لاهداف سياسيه ايران
تعتبر دائما طرفا اساسيا في ضمان امن
المياه الاقليميه والملاحه البحريه وهي
تتعامل بمسؤوليه مع هذا الام
نعتبر ان هذه الاتهامات تطرح لتظليل الراي
العام واخفاء الدعم الامريكي الشامل
لجرائم الكيان الصهيوني في
غزه